what is up everybody its Anna Mike here
for anime uproar and today I will be
breaking down the villain apocalypse in
boku no hero I am referring to the
unbelievable events that are continuing
to change the story forever more heroes
are dying more destruction is spreading
in all directions and the tone of the
entire series is shifting drastically
before our eyes this is unprecedented
and unbelievable shigaraki toga giganto
macchia dobby endeavor Deku Todoroki
hawks there is so much to talk about so
let's get into it if you enjoyed the
book no hero content on this channel and
you want us to keep it going please
leave a like to let me know it really
does help and if you happen to be new to
anime lore or you just haven't
subscribed yet please consider
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you have to go through the
trouble of clicking that bell and then
selecting the option that says o if you
don't do it you're gonna miss a lot of
our videos even if you're subscribed
it's just how you do works
feel free to hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram at anime uproar finally this
video will of course contain boku no
hero manga spoilers I'm talking about
the latest development in the story so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned after the absolute carnage
of the previous historic chapter I had
no idea what to expect would we learn
which heroes survived and which heroes
died would even more heroes lose their
lives as a result of chigan Rocky's
decay was gegen Tamaki a-- about to go
on a rampage man this was one of those
rare chapters where I was genuinely
scared to look at the next page because
I didn't want to see the potential death
of a character I care about so I mean it
was pretty much the same as reading any
attack on Titan chapter but obviously
with MHA this phenomenon is not as
common the previous chapter made it
clear that the boku no hero story has
entered a new much darker era and this
chapter absolutely confirmed
that fact the chapter starts off with
deck who attending to use what appear to
be condensed air blasts to blow the
decay back and away from his fellow hero
students however deku strategy doesn't
appear to be too effective in the long
term and otaku ensue you warned that the
decay is not stopping and that
everything is turning to dust a deeply
concerned deku thinks back to the time
when he had met shigaraki in person
during the class 1-a shopping trip
on that occasion she got a key told deku
about his quirk and how it works the
villain just needed to touch Deku with
all five of his fingers and Deku would
begin to decay and he would turn to dust
in about a minute's time the present
Deku then calls out she Guara keys name
as he realizes that all of this
destruction is indeed shigaraki is doing
what Deku must also realized that what
is happening here is far different from
the quirk that shigaraki had described
to him back on the day when they had met
I mean just think about it
she gareki said that if he touches that
goo directly with all five fingers it
would take about a minute for Deku to
turn to dust but here we have a type of
decay that is spreading wildly and that
is destroying entire buildings in a
matter of seconds so I mean dec who must
realize that shigaraki Square has
transformed into something completely
different from what we had seen before
at this point
Todoroki creates a massive ice wall
between the hero students and the decay
in order to delay the spread of the
decay for long enough for the students
to get away
burnin orders everyone to get back and
the students begin to run in the other
direction dec who even uses black whip
to help evacuate a bunch of people
including seemingly an entire bus that
is presumably filled with civilians
the fact that that goos black whip is
already so strong is definitely an
important development that we shouldn't
overlook with the new shigaraki being
strong to an insane degree dec who is
going to need to hurry and unlock his
additional quirks very quickly he looks
like he has mastered black whip but he
still has a long way to go before he can
unlock and master all the remaining
quirks which are currently high
within one for all as the heroes and
hero students are retreating nej'ta
is clearly worried about her mentor ryu
q and Todoroki is also visibly worried
about his mentor and father and ever and
you can't really blame them for worrying
for all they know the entire hospital
was just destroyed in a matter of
seconds and everyone who was in there
could already be dead
the chaos that shigaraki was able to
create in such a short period of time is
truly incredible and all the heroes and
heroes students who just saw this happen
must be terrified
I'm sure that most of them don't even
realize what is happening and who is
actually doing it so they're just seeing
a massive unending wave of destruction
in all directions truly a horrifying
sight for any hero and any hero student
to see the chapter then switches focus
to shigaraki sper spective shigaraki is
standing on top of the hill where the
hospital used to be and with his black
cape flailing in the wind he looks like
a freakin Sith Lord as he surveys the
devastation that he has just unleashed
shigaraki notices that the quark
destroying bullets that the villains
have been trying to reproduce based on
overhauls prototypes have been destroyed
shi gareki seems slightly disappointed
by this but even assuming that the
villains don't have any more copies of
these bullets and that these were the
only ones and they were indeed destroyed
does Shigure Aki really need them now
that he possesses all four one and his
awakened the King quark with the type of
power that shigaraki has now Kirk
destroying bullets might be superfluous
I mean why destroy the heroes quirks
when you can just destroy the heroes we
then see what appears to be a voice
inside shigaraki his head telling him to
do it is it just me or is horikoshi
trying to get us to compare shigaraki to
Anakin Skywalker and all for one to
Darth Sidious I am assuming that this do
it came from all-4-one since a part of
him is now probably residing within
shigaraki as a result of the fact that
she got Aki inherited all for once quark
factor it is definitely possible that
she got Aki and all for one now have a
special almost telepathic connection
just like the users of one for all she
got a key realizes that the fact that he
is currently awake must mean that the
heroes had attacked and Luka was forced
to wake him up early she gerak event
proceeds to call geek on Tamaki a-- and
tells him to come from the mansion here
to the hospital and to bring everyone
with him as gig on Tamaki a-- snaps
awake shigaraki declares that he is
about to destroy everything the focus
then shifts back to the mansion and it
is revealed that the mansion is located
about 80 kilometres away from the
hospital so that is a significant
distance probably about an hour's drive
by car depending on the quality of the
road had the mansion we see that get and
was able to create a giant mountain of
ice that basically stopped the hero raid
in its tracks
it appears that toh kweh ami was able to
successfully escape the reach of the
villains and it looks like he has been
able to take Hawkes out of harm's way at
least for now
fat gum sees Takuya me and he tells them
to keep heading to the rear more heroes
are there on standby and Takuya me and
the other students need to get to safety
as the experienced pro heroes continue
to fight the villains meanwhile a small
group of heroes is attacked by what
looks to be one of their own it is the
same hero with the snake quirk who had
attacked mr. compress and toga several
chapters ago but it turns out that this
hero was actually toga in disguise and
she ruthlessly cuts down a bunch of the
pro heroes by the looks of it
toga was definitely striking to kill and
some of the heroes that she just
attacked may actually have died dobby
also arrives downstairs and he asks mr.
compress for an update compress explains
that after twice as death toga pretty
much went nuts and attacked a bunch of
heroes without regard for her own safety
a clearly unstable and outraged toga
transforms back to her normal form and
she makes it clear that the heroes
aren't a way of her living in the life
that she wants to live as a result she
is determined to destroy them all and in
this moment togas conviction and
motivations remind me a lot of Shigure
aki himself both of these ruthless and
mentally unstable villains
are determined to destroy the hero
society at all costs and they will do
whatever it takes to make that happen
then as if all of this wasn't crazy
enough behind toga we see a massive
absolutely gigantic hand emerging from
the floor
this must be gig on Tamaki a-- although
his hand looks even bigger than I
remember I don't know if the size of his
hand is just being emphasized for
artistic purposes or if gig on Tamaki
a-- has somehow become even bigger than
before but either way we all know the
gig on Tamaki a-- can become huge and
that he is an absolute monster who can
level an entire city
so realtalk the heroes are in real
trouble here big big trouble
not only are the heroes about to be
dealing with gettin a crazed toga and an
Unleashed dobby
but now gig on Tamaki a-- has joined the
fray many heroes that we know well are
there in the thick of it including phat
gum mount lady and cement oohs and the
hard truth is that some of these heroes
may lose their lives in the near future
things are not looking good for the
heroes right now and this is no joke
the chapter ends as endeavour returns to
the site of shigga Rocky's destruction
back at the hospital after rescuing
miracle and presumably evacuating her to
a safe location
endeavour has returned to face off
against the newly awakened shigaraki
shigaraki is a bit surprised that the
number one pro hero has shown up so soon
after his awakening and that is how this
insane chapter ends with endeavor and
shigaraki preparing to clash in an epic
showdown between the overpowered number
one pro hero and the overpowered number
one villain also assuming that endeavor
did indeed rescue Motoko successfully I
want to give him props because miracle
is best girl and for this I definitely
respect and ever and thank him from the
bottom of my heart now I've been saying
this for a long time but we always knew
that this boku no hero war arc would
culminate in a massive final showdown
between the strongest heroes and the
strongest villains
first they were split up between two
different locations but now with
shigaraki summoning Egon Tamaki ah and
the other top villains to the hospital
or what's left of the hospital which is
practically nothing the stage is being
set for that big massive final showdown
and ever the number one pro hero is
already there deck who will be there and
things will get really intense and
really messy toga wants revenge and she
has completely lost it and with her
newly awakened ability to mimic the
quirks of others who knows what she
might be capable of doing Dobby is also
preparing for the showdown and it is
quite possible that the big moment
between him and endeavor the moment that
we've all been waiting for is about to
occur once the villains meet up at the
ruins of jakku hospital so much is
happening and there are so many
possibilities for what might happen next
the big question now is how long will it
take for gig on Tamaki and the others to
travel from the mansion to the hospital
giganto macchia is massive and he can be
fast but 80 kilometres is a significant
distance so could endeavor and the other
heroes stop shigaraki before he gets
back up unlikely but we'll have to wait
and see the other big thing from this
chapter that I want to know more about
is that voice that is seemingly coming
from inside chigan Aki's head the voice
that told him to do it
much like Palpatine told Anakin to do it
in Star Wars Episode three Revenge of
the Sith I am guessing that this is the
voice of all for one and that all from
one is speaking to shigaraki because she
gerak he now has the original all-4-one
quark so some part of all for one must
be inside his quark factor and by the
way I'm sure that the whole Palpatine
Anakin comparison is absolutely
intentional on the part of horikoshi he
loves Star Wars the name jakku from
jakku hospital is a reference to Star
Wars so this was definitely a little
easter egg that he is leaving out for us
but let me know what you guys think is
all for one now talking to Chikara key
through the all from one quark or is he
talking to him some other way may be
using a different quark or did that
voice come from someone else or
thing else please let me know you guys
think down in the comments below and
please tell me what you think is going
to happen next if you enjoyed this video
and you want to see more boku no hero
content right here on the channel please
leave a like to let me know it really
helps and if you happen to be new to
enemy uproar or you just haven't
subscribed yet please consider
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications feel free to hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar I
want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime opera patrons who make videos
like this one possible a very special
thank you to a friend a a disciple of
Lord Twigg o himself and I can't forget
our the one tear patrons the ones who
rise above all other clans including
ingrid ah a lull an atom of the world
steelers tyson queenie no acquired
respect pat a heffa Jonathan King desi
be Brandon Aviles Papa Smurf Emperor
otaku and richie martinez finally thank
you also to all our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings eldress Anatole Cassatt's key on
hell crews hi Sparky 65 cricket XP Ted
no Ted
Joe Stanton very gucci alicia akhter
animal a 69 jessica calif on dino
commune water bonnie parks so dr 12
rothwyn de hora emperor mitch loves
anime cynical Kraken and JC c walk up if
you enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value for you please
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these legendary people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see us space cowboys
[Music]